good morning health secretary daunting  job ahead what are your priorities  good morning i just want to start by  saying i think matt hancock worked  incredibly hard  he achieved a lot i'm sure he will have  more to offer  in public life i was honored to take up  this position i also know that it comes  with huge  responsibility and i will do everything  i can to make sure that i deliver for  the people of this great country we are  still  in a pandemic and i want to see that  come to an  end as soon as possible and that will be  my most  immediate priority to see that we can  return to normal  as soon and as quickly as possible now  i've got  a lot of work to do i'm sure you  appreciate that and if you  can excuse me i'd like to get on with it  thank you very much thank you very much  indeed